il appelle aujourd'hui qu'est ce que
vous aimeriez faire pour que ça change
quel message vous vouliez faire voudriez
faire passer parce que les ça fait des
années et des années que vous en parler
du manque de moyens et ça bouge pas
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez faire passer
comme message que vous avez encore un
espoir
si j'avais pas d'espoir je serai pas
habillée comme ça aujourd'hui
moi j'y croyais encore c'est difficile
c'est vraiment vraiment difficile à vos
enfants et si vous disent qu'ils veulent
devenir non non non si vous aviez de la
famille ou dans la police
oui oui et donc vous donc c était
heureux puisque vous avez voulu le faire
oui mais non pas que ça a changé
oui mais enfin je ne veux pas quitter
vienne plaie qu'est ce que vous auriez à
dire aux jeunes qu'ils qui vous traitent
voilà qu'est ce que vous auriez alors
dire aujourd'hui aux jeunes et aux moins
jeunes d'ailleurs je sais pas aux
personnes qui vous traitent dans la rue
comme vous dites vous avez dit on vous
traite
oui on en voit beaucoup notre intégrité
physique aussi vous avez déjà vécu des
moments où vous êtes dit ça va être
chaud pour moi oui
alors dans ces cas-là belge et jouer aux
cow-boys c'est à dire vous avez fait
quoi c'est à dire que j'ai gueulé plus
fort et en fait après en ayant peut-être
une approche une approche différente en
montrant on est obligé de montrer qu'on
n'a pas peur
et moi je me suis vu avec des caïds eu
de région parisienne notamment et non
parce qu'en fait on a pu encore discuté
et je lui ai dit je dis mais qu'est ce
que tu fais quoi
arrête ça va mal finir
et ça a mal fini parce que mais il a eu
un très grave accident de voiture
qu'est ce que est ce que vous essayez de
discuter avec les gens que vous
interpeller parce que c'est vrai qu'on
se dit moi il ya des policiers aussi
journée qui disent quand on est dans le
dialogue ça se passe plutôt bien avec
les jeunes ça dépend
joue une idée souvent dans les trois
premières secondes c'est à dire vraiment
c'est ça c'est là où ça on va être dans
dans une relation qui va dégénérer très
vite
ou bien quand il ya des policiers qui
sont plutôt cool avec l'ailé les gens
qu'ils appréhendent voilà ça se passe
plutôt bien on me dit souvent la voix
j'ai des potes que soient policiers ou
des potes voilà qui sont parés des
ennemis ça joue dans les trois premières
secondes est-ce que vous est ce que vous
trouvez est ce que vous n'avez pas de
plus dialoguer de aussi bien sûr et
alors ça ça va mieux ça dépend encore
une fois ça dépend des personnes ça
dépend des situations ça dépend ça
dépend de plein de choses
quand vous avez en face de vous en fait
ça se voit dans le regard le regard que
la personne porte sur vous quand c'était
un regard accusateur un regard noir un
regard agressif
moi j'ai un minot de 16 ans qui alors
que j'étais en train de les refermer sa
sa cellule de garde à vue la machine
grosse connerie il tapé dedans me disant
je vais te crever j'ai crevé il avait 16
ans je suis dit mais pourquoi tu me
parles comme ça est-ce qu'il se calmer
après les deux décennies passées discute
avec lui après j'ai essayé de discuter
avec lui et je suis énormément dans le
dialogue mais non ils voulaient rien
savoir
le problème à ce que parce que j'ai un
uniforme parce que on a un uniforme mais
de suite on est catalogué